his jab
on de la hoya or on vargas's body and
now vargas lands a big left hook counter
upstairs
oh yeah take it to him fernando vargas
is a two-time former boxing world
champion he competed in the olympics in
1996 and this saturday night his two
sons are fighting at mandalay bay
joining us now are fernando and his sons
we got fernando jr and amato down there
at the end and the champ is here as well
good to see you guys thank you for
having us it's great to have you here
fernando how do you feel how does it
make you feel saturday night your two
sons fighting on the same card wow man
it's very
exciting feelings you know me saying
it's like
to me it's such a blessing because you
know i'm living everything that i didn't
have
because i don't have a dad so
you know when you when i'm living this
through my kid's eyes it's like it's
amazing i'm like wow thank you lord so
it's a blessing for me and i just know
that my boys are ready and they were
going to put it on the show on so come
saturday night now fernando jr what's
going through your mind this week is the
big fight is on saturday night yeah i'm
just confident in the training uh my dad
put me through rigorous training put my
brother through rigorous training so
we're just ready to show up it's going
to be good now amano i have to ask you
because if you read any any boxing
publications they're calling you to the
future of boxing how does that make you
feel um we're working extremely hard
listening to my father my father has
been there done that and all we're just
doing is just continue to listen to this
man right here but we got three yeah
you know
the the vargas um dynasty yeah and so
you know we're excited about it it's a
blessing like i said to me and um you
know we can't forget about emiliano
fernando which is you know a
nine-time amateur champion and uh he's
in between brooke also no no fernando
you're uh you're you're four and all
right yes four enough okay walk me
through this week what you're training
when the weigh-ins take place walk me
through the week so yeah
press conference is thursday and then uh
the weigh-ins are friday and then the
fight saturday but you know i just got
to take it one step at a time the hard
part's done i did the running i did the
sparring i did the training now it's
time to go go out there and have fun now
uh motto did i ever tell you you guys
look like you could be in a boy band i
mean seriously you are the best looking
boxers i've ever seen thank you so much
man we work extremely hard in training
camp you know february 5th our hard work
is going to show yes we're definitely
excited to uh perform it's gonna be a
great weekend do you would you guys have
any nicknames like what are your
nicknames uh my dad gave me the nickname
amado el malvado fernando vargas yeah
that means tell him what that means he's
evil in spanish
junior so i took up my dad's name he's
known as aztec warriors the ferocious
one english it means the ferocious ones
i love it this can be good how do you
say loser in spanish i don't know what
is that
i don't know because
i was going to use that word with your
opponents on saturday night because
you're going
[Music]
he's the head coach and whatever he says
goes whatever what i like is he's the
eyes outside so whatever we we're
however it looks like on the inside you
know he has that eye how how it looks
like on the outside so it's a little bit
different but uh we're ready to go okay
one more quick question because amato
you were there oscar de la hoya you sold
the place out millions of people around
the world watching on pay-per-view
what's it like for you to enter the same
building and have a fight there on
saturday night uh
man it's an honor and a dream come true
to be
on a platform where my father has fought
many fights
and the lineage continues i love it uh
fernando we have to wrap up but how do
people watch the fight on saturday so
you can watch the fight on pbc um
it's going to be on the keith thurman
mario barrios undercard and uh we'll see
if we're on the pay-per-view card but
we're the very earliest bouts so if you
get if you got your ticket please go
ahead and show up early as soon as the
doors open and we appreciate the support
thank you love it thank you guys so much
we appreciate it good luck i don't need
luck on